the teenager in Vermont is accused of
planning an attack on his former high
school after a friend reported him to
police in New York State Jack Sawyer
pleaded not guilty to four charges
including attempted murder he allegedly
told the friend he was targeting the
high school in Fair Haven Vermont where
Sawyer was once a student Meg Oliver
spoke the young woman who reported him
he's now being called a hero meg good
morning good morning this investigation
spanned across state lines involving
agencies in New York and Vermont but it
would not have been possible if it
wasn't for the brave 17 year old who
told authorities that her friend might
be planning a deadly attack I texted him
saying that the school just got shot up
and he answered that's fantastic I a
hundred percent support it
Angela McDevitt says she met 18 year old
Jack Sawyer while at a treatment center
in Maine for troubled teens when you
were at the treatment facility what was
Jack Sawyer like I always struck me he
was very attentive to detail I'm very
kind
McDevitt says she stayed in touch with
Sawyer after they left the facility but
last week their friendship took a turn
according to a Vermont State Police
affidavit On February 11th
Sawyer wrote to McDevitt over Facebook
messenger saying just a few days ago I
was still plotting and shooting up my
old high school the next day he wrote
it's been the plan for two years and on
February 14th he allegedly praised the
Florida School shooting writing it's
just natural selection taken up a notch
they found them disturbing and knew I
had to contact somebody in Vermont to
look further into it one day after the
Florida shooting McDevitt met with her
New York high school resource officer
Evan trout who then contacted
authorities in Vermont people are
calling you a hero as well I followed
through with it and that's that's about
it I mean she definitely is the one who
who did the most of it according to the
affidavit when police interviewed Sawyer
he admitted he was planning a shooting
at Fair Haven Union High School and was
partly inspired by Columbine he bought a
shotgun a few days before police say
when they searched his car they found
the shotgun ammunition books
columbine a gas-mask a video recorder
and a journal detailing his plan titled
the Journal of an active shooter police
say Sawyer told them he was going to use
an ar-15
a handgun and his shotgun to carry out
the attack McDevitt says it wasn't easy
to report Sawyer but she is glad she did
what's your message to other students if
they hear of something like this or they
see a text message like this it's not
the matter of friendship if it's about
life's at hands it's you need to do what
you need to do according to the
affadavit Sawyer is diagnosed with ADHD
depression and anxiety
Sawyer's public defender said publicly
there are a lot of unproved allegations
in this case and it's a lot different
than initially portrayed angela told me
after the interview she's just hoping
that if any students are watching this
and they know something to just come
forward yes Thank You Angela because so
many students will read something like
that and say why didn't really take it
seriously where I didn't think he would
do it not in the climate we live in
today
you have to take it serious but
authorities will tell you if someone is
talking about harming themselves or
harming another person you have to
report that that's the rule and
absolutely yeah Thank You Mae Thank You
Megan Angela